yes pain yes hi I'm Alison and I say no
to a lot of things she's super funny
very generous super kind really
thoughtful but but he doesn't often like
to say yes to adventurous things for
this week I'm just gonna say yes to
everything yes people get up early it's
actually kind of nice oh don't you okay
you don't be sorry
you have a hair one before ah this is
just a scarf I usually do my best to
avoid bagel fried egg but today I'm
having one I'm saying yes to waxing
hahaha
Laura and my girlfriend invites me to go
surfing pretty much every weekend I
usually say no
she's definitely the kind of person that
is comfortable being uncomfortable and I
am NOT
I have missed out on a lot of things
that we could have been doing together
I'm here at dinner with my friends I
actually agreed to come out and have
dinner with them which is a new thing I
have tried to subscribe twice before but
have chickened out at the last minute I
could very easily have a panic attack
right now it's like the one thing that I
have like really tried to force myself
to do and I have never done it you ready
for this
no we're doing anyway okay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
do it again this is what being a yes
person is like I think I can do it
[Music]
alright let's do something a little more
fun let's go right all the way down oh
my god